um yeah I had an experience with Yosef
posing in Chicago why I came down love
Yosef and this we were sitting down
after my two shows we're not high we're
at though downstairs there's a
downstairs area enjoy this really cool
downstairs borrow that bar yeah you know
everyone yeah yeah went down there and
there was a young man who he had long
hair and a nose ring one of those bull
rings and his nose which has never
attracted and he smelled strong it's not
like a water buffalo he had he had a
blonde bob like a girl's haircut mm-hmm
he had very loose he was a Don oh I was
there and I had a very loose shirt on
and in sandals okay he was like can I
talk to you and I was sitting down I go
what because can I please talk to you
and I go shooting I love you I love you
so much and he hugged me and I went oh
you smell so strong yes sir
strong like like like like the Parmesan
cheese in a lord who like soup he
smelled like bad soup no they cometh yes
and I went okay somebody hasn't taken a
shower but that's okay very drunk and a
little drugged up I didn't know what to
say but he said I just love you and
thank you and I love you and I said well
thank you and he hugged me again and I
said thank you might be alone with me
hug me again okay there was a lot of
hugging and holding me and when you hug
a man when you press your your
three-piece set against the other man's
three-piece set that's where things get
gonzo he was conjuring up Oh gonzo it
went gonzo gonzo and went burglar man
yeah he wanted to be you know when you
you used that your bump of iPhone's to
exchange information and he did the same
he I phoned me maybe that's we found you
fist bump dick heads with yes yes we
gonzo nosed and so I went okay and I
broke away and I'm a guy comes back as a
guy with the nose yeah I'm talking to
you if his microphone akka and he just
looks at me and he goes he goes yeah he
sits down he's trying to get in on the
conversation I'm like I'll just ignore
me though he's white he he falls into a
cross-legged
set he was in he just falls in and
pushes his hair his beautiful blonde
little Bob back and he's waiting and
finally just stands up and he goes
I need to talk to can you just scoot
scoot and I got no no actually there's
no room because there's no room because
can you just scoot he's trying to sit on
my lap and finally I said no I turn him
back around and then he looks at me and
he goes huh and he comes in to kiss me
and you're set just goes hey hey pushes
the guy's face away whoa whoa whoa whoa
take it - give me the copy whoa Jim I
was like I grab the guy go thank you
thank you I just can't talk right now
and his girl his friend took him away
then did you slimy a number and did you
big son laughs no but I did I did bang
him with his face with his blonde face
in the pillow Wow would you were this
him so you asked me dude not really she
was so drunk and Jim was traumatized I
feel like when I went to keep searching
went ah yeah it was weird man it was
super worried it was very very strange
it was very aggressive but he was so he
was not just drunk he was drugged
something was up he was sitting on a
side active Hill sitting on the side
sitting down like Indian style by the
table just staring at Brian he was a
young boy he was a young man he was
probably no 22 Playboy yeah and I'm 51
yeah yes it's over fob he had a daddy
complex
yeah he had daddy complex heaven forbid
that's a young attractive girl like why
how did that happen a young doctor like
I just can't take you know yeah he is
married when I was when I was young I
come off stage and I had this Colombian
girl who just was so good-looking it's
so good-looking
and she goes you're so hot you're so hot
you're just so hot and she was looking
at me like she was lost professional she
was a law of sessional I now what daddy
paid the bill oh yeah and then I don't
want to be rude so you know made the
bills yeah and then then I remember
later on she goes you know I'm pregnant
have you ever been in this someone so
badly that you just want to drink their
blood oh wow and I went sure haven't
miss Vampira
have a good night have a good night
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]